Joan referred to this this morning you
see I think what happened is women
outsmarted themselves the men were off
silently hunting and practicing being
quiet as they stalk their prey the women
were creating language in order to
describe the taxonomy of these various
food plants of which they probably could
distinguish four or five hundred plants
seasons soil conditions variants unusual
conditions of all sorts which parts of
the plant were edible which were
poisonous so forth and so on and as
always happens when you succeed in an
enterprise where you seek control you
inevitably simplify so the women became
so conversant with the power of plants
that they realized they need no longer
gather them they could grow them and
then they'd realize they wouldn't of
course grow all the plants they knew
about they would only grow those plants
that grew easily produced large fruit
and had a big payback and suddenly the
women undercut their own power base and
it became possible to silently practice
very dulling agriculture and the and the
gods then became not the gods of the
orgy and the hunt and the wild plants
but the gods became corn gods and wheat
gods and it became important to be able
to get up early in the morning and walk
off to your field and weed and less
important to be able to ecstatically
prophesy and have visions well that's
just one scenario but it's worth talking
about I think because how we image our
emergency out of animal organization is
going to
very deeply how we image our transition
into a transcendental realm that's why I
talk about what I call the archaic
revival rather than the new-age all this
talk about shamanism is a reaching back
fifteen twenty five thousand years to
those models to steady us
we should go out the way we came in
which means as a partnership society as
a psychedelic society as a tribal
society and so by thinking about the
origins we actually gain an intimation
of the future yes oh yeah I mean it is
all of a piece this the suppression of
women it's a complicated thing I mean it
has to do with solar calendars which we
can't which gained prominence with the
invention of Agriculture
see I think the invention of agriculture
was where it began to go wrong well some
people say it was the domestication of
the horse or cities or this Anapa tea
people idealize the proto Agra the
Neolithic and think that this was fine
but I think already in place were
notions of hanging on to the land of
storing well of cooperating coerced
cooperation in the production of food a
simplified vocabulary about nature all
of these things were put in place by the
Neolithic but you know Arthur Young some
of you may know his theories he has this
idea that every state of freedom is
accomplished by a descent
into a state of bondage and so that for
instance you know molecular chemistry is
the product of the molecular bond if you
have chemical systems with so much
energy that there can be no molecular
bonding then you all you have is atomic
chemistry you have not the possibility
of organic chemistry so the coming and
going of the male ego the coming and
going of the repression of women and the
feminine seems to be related to how much
exposure there is to these wild plant
States because that you see women come
up against it because they bury the dead
they birth the living they know that all
is not as it appears to be they are
informed of the fact that culture is a
charade but men believe all this stuff